yeah he certainly has I think we're going to see
a lot from Curtis Lazar as far as that dirty work
and paying attention to detail doing the things
like finishing checks every shift it's just a
test to this depth that the Devils have and really
intrigued to see how this power play fares this
year last year finished 13th from the National
Hockey League they're looking to be oh there's
a goal right off the bat of the power play cell
jper brat comes and now Sal the devils are 6 for
14 on the power play this pre-season well Bill
what we're seeing is exactly what I was talking
about the chemistry is here in the power play you
got dougy Hamilton quarterbacking that one with
some threats as well so we're really intrigued
to see how this power play goes because yes the
power play won't win you necessarily face Downy
cup guarantee that but in the regular season
when you have so many Dynamic players like the
Devils do the power play has to be connecting
because each one of those guys he just can't
miss right now he he has played that well and
what a shot that was on a little feed from Jack
Hughes on the power play to give the Devils the
lead so brat from M Hughes to put the Devils
on top Luke Hughes rips and scores Eric holl is
screening in front and it's two nothing [Music]
Devils well the Devils feed up a quick call on
the power play the beautiful wrist shot shot off
the far post as you see the Devils move the puck
around goes to Luke Hughes no hesitation nice
little chip pass on the back hand from poot to
the high slot to Mercer finds Luke Hughes and he
lets it rip they're still they continue to miss
Philip heed that had a good skate this morning
before the team went on for uh the morning skate
hedel was out there and uh had a good workout
so they're they're hopeful that he's going to be
ready for the season opener on the 12th in Buffalo
again that's eight nights away the Rangers at the
Sabers that same night the Devils host the Red
Wings both teams will start the regular season
Meer in front oh heer's poke hit the post and
quick pounces on the rebound from Meer to eer
Sean ther quickly gets it up to Holtz real nice
OneTouch pass to Meyer as they enter the zone and
heer barrels to the net look at that pass between
the legs of trouba the puck is rolling and Nico
he I had a rough ride getting up but guys yeah
great first Parry for the Devils for sure I expect
a lot more in the second from the Rangers we saw
that in Madison Square guarden as a matter of fact
where John Marino recovers there I know Joe you
said that Blake just seems really happy to be
part of this Rangers group and here he is in the
slot getting it down L and vanck covers as will
[__] couldn't really Corral it in front but he's
a very good passer of the puck watch this little
tip pass right there in front and that allows
will [__] to get a a chance but vanich makes
a good save all you see [__] he got a little
piece that puck John Marino he tried that cross
ice pass all the way from the right boards in his
own Zone and it was picked off by troch I believe
there who made a good defensive play goodro wins
the face off raen Schneider throws it through the
mixer and into the corner where Coley bangs bodies
with Dawson Mercer and now Brendan Smith starts
It Forward third line of Mercer poot and holla
could be a really good third line Dawson Mercer
today said it's three guys who aren't afraid to
get their nose dirty the all score as well raen
Schneider sends it wide rebound goes home will
Coy on the rebound sticks it underneath VC vanich
as he played the bounce well off the boards you
know Peter lolet made a change a little little
bit of a jump here good work here this shot by
Schneider goes wide but kie right in front of
the net is there and waste no time putting it in
yeah good instincts and good positioning as that
puck cars perfectly as Schneider missed the that
you talked about Joe but off the end wall and as
we saw a good opportunity for Holtz he shot
it high he's he got a shot in the slot I'm a
little older than you just a little bit doesn't
feel like anybody is Anymore Joe but oh wait oh
good good pass to team o Meer he's racing trba
he's taking down rebound score Dawson Mercer
on the power [Music] [Applause] play the goal
let's take a look at our million dollar replay
brought to you by the New Jersey Lottery remember
anything can happen in Jersey great stretch pass
to team o Myers as he gets in behind trouba
it didn't look like a penalty was going to be
called initially I thought it maybe was a trip
but trouba goes crashing into the net this is
what you love about Meer he drives the net hard
even though he's taken down and look at Dawson
Mercer followed up and Joe quickly the difference
between J glant and Peter Lavette is just that a
little more aggressive look at Sean ther walked to
the front and Jonathan Quick ends up on top of the
puck five on three for the Rangers caner across
the bage had faked it oh po check John Marino
looking to break inage that trying to recover
Marino charging in shorthanded quick Stones
him Marino read that play perfectly as paner May
gone back to the well one too many times that was
all about paner is more of a passer than he is a
shooter Marino knew it that he was going to try
and get it to a bandage at who's got the excellent
shot from that side and nearly scored a three on
five 40 seconds left on the five on three paner
takes it up top again Glides it across with a
seam pass it skips in off vanck Adam Fox will get
credited for the goal as he was trying to slide
it into the slot and it bounced off the devil's
net minder yeah I I think Sean ther when he went
down to one leg it might have went off his leg as
well good effort by Sean ther but unfortunately a
bad result after Marina mention gets a great
chance and you see Fox is trying to find the
scam passing yeah it went right off the right
glove I believe yep of Sean ther and redirects
past vanich not much vanich can do on that you
know sometimes you have moments like that Luke
Hughes blast it wide rebound oh quick scolls out
to make a save on brat that in pre-season you can
get away with but that'll be something I'm sure
that will not be accepted in the regular season
Devils two for three on the power play already
tonight they just nearly went to three for four
Jack Hughes blasts now they're three for four
Hugh scores this power play is going to put the
league on notice absolute laser from Jack Hughes
had a lot of regular season form and then some
as far as the chemistry and there's the give and
goal from the corner with tooi Hughes feeds to FY
he stops gets the stick cocked ready to go their
pp's been cooking during this pre-season got to be
able to win your games when you're not scoring
at even strength or you know tight games where
you you need one goal and you get an opportunity
in the power play well I couldn't get Nico heer
to spill all the secrets turned over to Z banish
at and oh talk about a big timely save for V vage
gets it there we see so many power plays you
know try to be too much just a misplay there
and and zaban with a great chance to make this a
one goal game just over skating the puck and 42
game and vanich comes up big minute 10 left on the
power PL spilled in front and vanich makes another
good save wave it off that was played with a high
stick by Jimmy vzy well over the crossbar as he
volley balled it downman at Center only I can
get a wedge like that you can't no canny Lazar
absolutely got out there on Monday as a matter
of fact with this nice weather Joe I told you
it's not that I don't play so I don't get to spin
like that b sees it skip right on by cols and taco
come together and capital Taco had it momentarily
before teimo Meer newly 28 for New Jersey gets in
it net is empty and here's ni Heir slamming it
inam moay with the chip will get the assist slam
dunk goal for heer is first the preseason puts the
Devils ahead by three the Devils chip it out High
bucks bouncing Holtz with a little pass to heer
he makes a Nifty little play with the stick to
turn the blade over Devils get a pretty solid
effort great special teams and that Keys a 52
New Jersey win over New York these teams meet for
real in a couple of months in the regular season